your doctor may recommend
intensity-modulated radiation therapy a
procedure that treats certain forms of
cancer to kill cancer cells or control
their growth the cells in the body grow
and divide as part of the normal cell
cycle the cell's nucleus controls this
process
inside each nucleus genetic material
called DNA contains the instructions for
directing this process
sometimes the cells DNA becomes damaged
normally the DNA responds by either
repairing itself or instructing the cell
to die
in cancer however the parts of the cells
DNA that direct cell division become
damaged
sections are damaged the DNA is unable
to repair itself
instead the unrepaired DNA causes the
cell to grow and divide uncontrollably
into more damaged cells called cancer
cells
a tumor forms as the cancer cells
multiply and displace the normal cells
radiation kills cancer cells by
inflicting overwhelming damage to their
DNA
the tumor shrinks as the cells stop
dividing and die
if the tumor is in your head your
radiation therapist may make a mesh
frame or mask that will keep you
positioned correctly during the IMRT
or you will get small permanent tattoos
to help align the imrt
next your therapist will do a CT scan of
your head to get a detailed picture of
your tumor and its borders
your doctor will use the scans to
specify the three-dimensional shape of
your tumor and vital tissues nearby
the tumors shape size type and location
help your doctor determine how the IMRT
beam should be adjusted to hit your
tumor and avoid healthy tissue
during your procedure a medical Linear
Accelerator will deliver an x-ray beam
to your tumor
a computer inside the accelerator will
adjust the beam with a device called a
collimator
the collimator will adjust or modulate
the intensity direction and shape of the
radiation beam this feature allows
higher doses of radiation to be
delivered to your tumor while sparing
your healthy tissue around it
you may receive many radiation
treatments over days or weeks this
allows your body to recover between
treatments and to kill as many cancer
cells as possible
side effects are usually mild and occur
only in the treatment area common side
effects include localized skin
irritation localized hair loss or
inflammation and swelling near the tumor
location